[Music]  understood  now we are not afraid  although we know there's  knew much could  there can be miracles  [Music]  when you  believe somehow  you will when you  believe  [Music]  hope seems like the  summer bursts too swiftly flown away  and now i'm standing here  my heart's so full i can't explain  seeking faith and speaking words i never  thought i'd say  [Music]  there can be miracles  when you believe  [Applause]  who knows what miracles  you cannot cheat  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  and it's easy to give in  see your fears  [Music]  hope is very  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  somehow  somehow somehow  [Music]  you  when you  believe  [Music]  happy passover everyone stay healthy and  safe